all right tom brady's now in uh tampa
bay not new orleans almost said new
orleans the four teams in the nfc south
will be drafting next week let's start
with the saints the saints can't leave
the draft without what chris
well to me you know again the saints are
one of the better organized orchestrated
football rosters in the whole league
right now there's not a lot of huge
glaring needs i mean to me it comes down
to two things mike maybe you got a
different view here but it would be
either linebacker
or pass rusher i think at the end of the
day you know and the more i look at it
the more i want to say pass rusher um
you know and i know they have marcus
davenport but he's been injured a lot
through the first few years of his
career hasn't really performed up to
where i think they were hoping as far as
trading first round picks to get him cam
jordan's getting up there in age you
know that would be an area i would look
at it's either that or a middle
linebacker and you know again they're
sitting in the spot at number 24 in the
first round where there could be some
middle linebackers that certainly make a
difference for their football team i
guess i would say if you had equal on
both sides i would rather the pass
rusher uh right now for a team that you
know again has had moments of being
somewhat average on past defense this
would help them just get there with the
front four not blitz but i look at pass
rusher more than anything is a position
i'd like to see them bolster
and to the extent that you're in a
division with tom brady and you're going
to face it twice this year and next year
you got to get bodies that can get after
him and disrupt him especially if he's
going to be holding on to the football a
little bit longer than he has in the
past because the bruce aryan's offense
trying to get the ball down the field so
you always have to view your draft needs
through the prism of the teams you play
twice per year and you've got two really
good quarterbacks in matt ryan and tom
brady and a guy in teddy bridgewater who
could end up being very good as well now
that he's got a chance to be a starter
again after five years uh as not a
starter so it'll be interesting four
years uh more accurately uh not being a
starter it'll be interesting to see what
the saints do there i think running back
is something they need to consider
because latavius murray has plenty of
wear and tear alvin camaro was banged up
last year he's gonna want a big contract
and they've constantly used that
rotation of two and three guys and i
think that that
even though murray was good last year
they lost something when mark
was a guy to compliment alvin kamara and
i think you need somebody who can bring
more punch over a longer period of time
than what murray can do
yeah i mean
i think you're right you're spot on in a
lot of ways there mike they you know
it's an important position to that
offense you're right they don't want to
lose one of those guys and then go oh
man we can't do this on the offensive
side of the ball now because we lost
alvin kamara we don't have a guy we
could trust in the pass game so
i'm not mad at you with that thought and
again as we talked about with the
running backs in the first hour you got
to be thinking about drafting one every
three to four years you know the
evidence is there now for us to know
that after three or four years
most running backs start to go on a big
decline as far as their physical ability
and i think it's about the time frame of
when you need to start thinking about
refreshing your you know that position
on your roster
and if you have two or three
they last longer in their nfl careers
and maybe you don't have to pay them
quite as much because they never become
that superstar talent and they
understand it's in their interest to
stretch it out even farther all right
the falcons can't leave the draft
without what chris
well this is an easy one to me this is
corner cornerback all the way you know
they've done a good job as far as you
know adding some splash to their roster
and free agency traded for haydenhurst
you know got dante fowler in free agency
so they got a big time pass rusher but i
gotta look at corner you know isaiah
oliver's there right now bleedy ray
wilson you know of course we know
desmond you know truffant's not there
robert offered gun
you know i don't look at them right now
and feel warm and cozy about the
cornerback position isaiah oliver a guy
they dropped it out of colorado in the
second round a few years back he's been
good but not great lady ray wilson's
been a little bit of a career journeyman
you know to me that's an area of the
football team that i think is is glaring
that says they need improvement it's
right there the defensive line pretty
good linebacker is pretty good safeties
are good when healthy you know they've
adjusted the o line you know running
back you can debate there but i think
corner more than anything is the
position i look at
yeah and again this is another one of
those needs that is crafted by
where you are you're dealing with the
saints twice a year you're dealing with
tom brady now twice a year and with true
font gone a guy they released in the
offseason they're going to need to
upgrade there so i agree with you on
that and offensively look i it's it's
not going to hurt to have uh some more
offensive lineman to keep matt ryan
upright he missed some time last year i
think he was banged up a little bit had
an ankle problem just a game or two you
don't want him being injured you're
gonna fade from the pack quickly if he's
not healthy and ready to go all right
buccaneers can't leave the draft without
what
well it's an offensive tackle i mean if
you want tom brady to play for two more
years you better get a tackle and
protect them i mean you know you know we
don't want tampa bay injury or something
like that i mean that's not what we want
but
regardless they need you know demar
dodson i think he's still out there as
far as free agent he was their starting
right tackle the last two years
and maybe i missed it i don't think
they've resigned them but whether they
resigned them or not they need to draft
the position you know they just don't
have enough depth they got to prepare
for yeah a guy like dotson leaving
somewhere here if they did resign them
and i'm wrong i don't think they did to
replace him regardless they need more
young talent at the position and i think
that would be the thing uh that they
would address they need a starting
offensive tackle to not only help their
their their run game but to protect
brady and have that bruce aries risk it
no biscuit type of mentality if you want
to throw the ball aggressively down the
field you need time to throw the ball
aggressively down the field so that to
me is the one that makes the most sense
for sure with the tampa bay buccaneers
yeah and look i'm going to focus on the
interior offensive line just to have
depth have enough guys have enough
you with brady the concern is up the
middle right and i understand they need
to have tackles too especially if you're
going to hold the ball longer the
pocket's going to collapse more from the
outside and brady may not be able to
step up and move like he once did it's
the arm that will stay it's the legs
that will go away but you you don't want
to be vulnerable up the middle we've
seen too many times when
when there's been pressure up the middle
in brady's face that's when you get to
him that's when he starts looking down
instead of looking down the field and
the patriots have done a good job for
the most part keeping that from
happening to him that's going to be a
challenge in tampa bay because once that
that leak arises in the middle of the
offensive line that's when you have an
opportunity to really hamper tom brady's
effectiveness all right the panthers
can't leave the draft without what
well i look at them offensively and feel
pretty good about them defensively man
there's some holes i mean you lost james
bradbury in in free agency loutiquely
retired
you know they've lost vernon butler uh
and don terry poe as far as defensive
tackles kawan short the other defensive
tackle they paid a lot of money to who
was a star just a few years ago
this has just been
good not great the last few years so i
look at d tackle as being the position
that i think they need to upgrade the
most you know and them you know and we i
should have hit this with tampa a minute
ago but with carolina where they're
sitting at in the first round you know
they should have a pick of the litter as
far as the defensive tackle is concerned
i mean there's two guys that i think
stand out for the rest as far as javon
kinlaw or brown from auburn as being the
two best defensive tackles in the draft
and i would think for sure one of them
is there for carolina to take in the top
ten but that is certainly a position i
look at to go they don't have enough on
their roster right now let alone you
know enough good ones uh they need depth
and more talented position so d tackle
is where i go michael
yeah now that they have a new head coach
in matt rule who up clearly has his
vision for how he's going to do things
and they've made major changes at the
quarterback position i think they need a
quarterback that they can develop they
don't have to rush him to the field
they're paying teddy bridgewater
three years 63 million but as a
practical matter i think he's got the
job for two seasons
to get a guy ready you get you get a guy
matt rules comfortable with that that
can grow and develop and that ted you
know look teddy i feel bad for teddy
bridgewater that he'd only be there for
two years and then get thrown overboard
again but i almost feel like he's kind
of accepted that that's his fate that
he's just gonna go wherever he's needed
whenever he's needed and uh i think that
that it's time for the panthers to be
thinking about getting a young
quarterback that will be that guy who
takes over and is there for 10 years or
longer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports